hemos ya hecho un montón de vídeos para
establecer un montón de verdades
relacionadas con integrales definidas de
combinaciones de funciones
trigonométricas para poder tener una
base matemática sólida para poder hallar
coeficientes de furia y creo que en
realidad sólo nos falta un vídeo más en
el último vídeo nosotros dijimos que la
integral de 0 a 2 pi del producto de
senos de seno de emt por seno de nt de
verdad por supuesto cuando m yenes son
enteros pero m es distinto de n y m es
distinto de menos n en este caso vale 0
sin embargo cuando m y n son iguales
entonces la integral de 0 a 2 pi del
seno al cuadrado que sí que sería cuando
m n son iguales verdad seno cuadrado de
mt vale pi y quizás lo que no dije en el
vídeo anterior es que esto es válido
cuando m es un entero no nulo verdad
porque si m fuera cero verdad que sería
cuando en mención entero nulo es que
cero verdad si me fuera cero el seno al
cuadrado de cero sería cero y la
integral de cero vuelve a ser cero
y este resultado no sería válido cuando
m es 0 muy bien en este vídeo lo que
vamos a hacer es esencialmente lo mismo
pero ahora vamos a intercambiar el papel
de seno por el de coseno muy bien vamos
a ver que el integral de ese grado speed
el coseno de mt por el coseno de nt vale
cero cuando m y n son enteros pero m es
distinto de m&m es distinto de menos n y
también la integral de 0 a 2 pi del
coseno cuadrado dmt
espí cuando m es un entero no nulo muy
bien así que vamos a hacer el primero y
como lo hicimos en el vídeo anterior
vamos a reescribir esto que tenemos aquí
con alguna identidad trigonométricas que
sea útil muy bien y si quizás este tema
no te resulta familiar familiar te
recomiendo que lo revise en algún vídeo
aquí en khan academia lo que vamos a
hacer es reescribir esto que tenemos
adentro como un medio del coseno de m -
n que multiplica t
todo esto va dentro del coche no más
el coseno de m más n que multiplica t
implica t
y todo esto vamos a integrarlo con
respecto a t muy bien y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es nuevamente distribuir
este producto y separar las integrales
entonces lo que tendríamos es lo
siguiente sería un medio un medio de la
integral de 0 a 2 y delko seno del
coseno de m - n porte muy bien y esto
vamos a integrarlo con respecto a t más
ahora sería otra vez un medio de la
integral de 0 a 2 pi
a dos del coseno del coseno de m más n
que multiplica t y otra vez vamos a
hacerlo con respecto a t muy bien
entonces vamos a tomar justamente este
caso vamos a tomar el caso en que m no
es n iv que m es distinto de menos cn y
por supuesto vamos a suponer que m n son
números enteros verdad si m y n son
enteros entonces m
n es un entero pero como m no es igual a
n
este es un entero no no lo verdad no es
cero lo mismo pasa con este como m
no es menos n esto no se puede anular y
entonces es un entero no nulo y nosotros
ya sabemos desde hace muchos vídeos
verdad que la integral del coche no de
un entero por t de 0 a 2 pi es 0 para
cualquier m que sea entero no no lo
justamente nuestros dos casos de aquí
verdad entonces esta integral vale 0
esta otra integral vale 0
cada una de ellas está siendo
multiplicada por un medio entonces un
medio por 00 un medio por cero es cero y
luego tenemos 0 + 0
entonces justamente tendremos que todo
esto vale cero y tenemos esta primera
afirmación muy bien así que vamos a
borrar todo esto vamos a borrar todo
esto para dejar listas digamos las
cuentas que ya tenemos y que vamos a
utilizar para el siguiente caso entonces
este ya lo tenemos hecho y ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa cuando m es igual a n
entonces si m es igual a n déjenme bajar
un poquito si m es igual a n que es lo
que tenemos bueno por supuesto también
vamos a suponer que m es distinto de 0
verdad aquí hay que pedir que me sea un
entero no nulo
entonces si m es igual a n entonces esto
de aquí vale 0 verdad y por supuesto el
coseno de 0 vale 1 entonces todo esto
vale 1 y aquí lo que tendremos es que m
n pues sería 2 m que es algún
verdad entonces si nosotros reescribimos
esto sería vamos a ponerlo así esto
sería un medio por la integral de 0 a 2
pi de uno de uno por bueno vamos a poner
de verdad más un medio
en medio de la integral de 0 a 2 pi del
coseno de 2 mt el coseno de 2 m t con
respecto a t nuevamente tenemos aquí una
integral de 0 a 2 pi del coseno de uno
de un entero verdad porque 2 m es un
entero y es un entero no nulo porque m
no es 0 verdad multiplicando a t
integramos respecto a t y entonces toda
esta integral vale 0
toda esta integral vale 0 al
multiplicarlo por un medio nos vuelve a
dar 0 y aquí lo que tenemos es lo
siguiente la integral de 0 a 2 pi de 1
con respecto a t entonces esto es un
medio porte evaluado desde cero a dos y
verdad que esto sería un medio que
multiplica a 2 y -0 2 - 0 2 2 pi y al
dividirlo entre 2 simplemente nos da y
entonces el resultado que habíamos
anticipado desde acá arriba es válido
verdad
ya habiendo establecido estas dos
relaciones nuevas tenemos un montón de
herramientas para calcular los
coeficientes de furia que en realidad es
lo que haremos en el siguiente vídeo y
que definitivamente es algo muy
emocionante